- Well, I think it's cool
that you produce, write,
and do these movies yourself.
- Yes.
- I mean, it's crazy stuff,
but it's crazy like a fox
'cause you're pretty much
the whole movie company, aren't you?
- Well, me and my partners,
Spike Jonze and Jeff Tremaine
we all do it ourselves.
- [Jay] Right, but you know what I mean.
It isn't one of these things-
- Yeah.
- [Jay] Where Warner Brother gets 2%
and somebody in the other studio gets 9%,
you know what I mean, those things?
So you can pretty much, you
know where all the money goes.
- Yeah, if you're gonna wreck yourself
you might as well get paid
for it, you know? (laughs)
- Right, right, exactly,
exactly, exactly, exactly.
Okay, so what can we expect?
I know we can expect to
see you in the movie.
(Johnny laughing)
but tell me some more.
- Oh my goodness.
Well there's fun with bulls.
There's always a bull.
It's probably the worst
bull hit I've ever taken.
- [Jay] Really?
- Spend the weekend in the hospital.
- So no bull, this is the worst bull-
- [Johnny] Yeah, no bull, you know what.
- Ah yeah, okay.
- Yeah, everything you see is real.
That's one thing we have on our side
in the "Jackass" movies.
It's all, it's the truth.
- Well see, that's okay 'cause
in most Hollywood films,
there'd be a stuntman or a sensible person
doing some sort of CGI.
- [Johnny] Right.
- You actually kill the
people, yeah, yeah. (chuckles)
- Yeah, no, we wreck the guys.
They don't know what's
coming when they walk on set.
So by the end of the film,
they're suffering from PTSD.
They are like, you can
walk up behind someone
and just put your finger on their shoulder
and they'll go down.
- Right, just because-
- Yeah, they're in terror.
- Now, you come from a family-
- I'd like to say I feel bad but I don't.
(audience laughing)